in this era of major movie studios
earmarking their spots on the release
scheduled years ahead of time it isn't
too early to start making box office
predictions for 2018 among the already
dozens of promising project slated for
release here are some of the movies
we're projecting to hit big black
panther before we finally get to
Avengers infinity war the Marvel
Cinematic Universe is going to make a
quick stop in Wakanda home of
everybody's favorite super-powered
feline the black panther in his first
stand-alone film T'Challa has returned
home after his dad's tragic death and
Captain America Civil War and now he's
set to rule his technological Wonderland
unfortunately according to the official
plot description the new king will find
himself facing a powerful old enemy
black panther prowls into theaters
February 16
tomb raider Alicia vikander is taking
the place of Angelina Jolie starring is
one of the greatest video game
characters of all time Lara Croft in the
reboot Croft as a bike courier inspired
by video messages from her late father
to journey into the jungle and find the
mysterious mother of death a tomb that
might in the world if opened
unfortunately for Croft she's not the
only one interested in the tomb with an
oscar-winning actress as the lead we're
pretty psyched to see the new Lara Croft
raid movie theaters everywhere come
March 16th Pacific Rim uprising the Pan
Pacific Defense Corps is gearing up for
a rematch in Pacific Rim uprising
sadly Guillermo del Toro will only be
producing this time but the science
fiction spectacle is an incredibly
capable hands the sequel will be
directed by Steven s tonight the guy in
charge of Spartacus and daredevil and
the film will star John boyega from the
new Star Wars trilogy if you're psyched
for two hours of kaiju killing fun get
ready to cancel the apocalypse on March
23rd ready player one based on the
best-selling novel by Ernest Cline
ready player one looks like the ultimate
pop-culture mash up the plot features
elements from games like overwatch and
Street Fighter as well as every 80s
movie imaginable including Tron Akira
and a Nightmare on Elm Street and of
course it's directed by the king of 1980
cinema himself Steven Spielberg in
addition to all the orcs and DeLoreans
the plot will focus on a young kid named
Wade Watts who escapes his impoverished
life by retreating into the Oasis the
ultimate virtual reality world New
Mutants now that the x-men movies have
exhausted pretty much every timeline
they can leap into and out of with
Logan's dismal glimpse of the future
it's time for the new mutants to start
running the school new mutants will
likely introduce a bevy of new talented
teens who as in the comic spin-off
series of the same name are trained by
Charles Xavier to emerge as a new class
of heroes it remains to be seen which of
the comics most fascinating kids will
make it into the new generation of the
x-men film series but we'll find out on
April 13th when new mutants hits
theaters
Super Troopers - when Super Troopers
came out in 2001 the cop comedy failed
to impress critics but over the years
it's morphed into a genuine cult classic
17 years and one successful IndieGoGo
campaign later
it looks like the members of Broken
Lizard will finally bring their
prankster patrolman back to the big
screen on April 20th according to
Entertainment Weekly the plot will focus
on the original five troopers as they're
called in to set up a new highway patrol
station in an area at the center of a
border dispute between the u.s. and
Canada Avengers infinity war in 2008
Tony Stark launched the Marvel Cinematic
Universe when he built a robot suit heat
up a bunch of terrorists and boldly
declared I am Iron Man
since then moviegoers have been
introduced to a whole host of
superheroes as well as a collection of
mysterious stones that keep popping up
across the universe and now 18 movies
later all our heroes are going to
converge in one epic battle against the
biggest bad guy in the galaxy a space
Titan with the world's deadliest fashion
accessory Avengers infinity war is the
ultimate cinematic crossover jump into
the fray on May 4th solo a Star Wars
story Ron Howard's solo a Star Wars
story promises fans the origin story of
everyone's favorite scruffy-looking
nerf-herder plot details are a little
scarce but we do know alden ehrenreich
stars as han solo donald glover will
appear as Lando
Woody Harrelson will star as Hans mentor
Beckett and we'll get to see Han meet up
with Chewbacca and become a snarky space
cowboy rest assured this space opera
will make a truckload of cash and rile
up the fan base for better or worse come
May 25th Deadpool
- when Deadpool hit theaters in 2016 it
grossed around 783 million dollars and
became the highest-grossing r-rated
movie in cinematic history the sequel
has a lot to live up to but Deadpool -
looks like a lot of foul-mouthed fun
with a dynamite cast there's also some
impressive talent behind the camera
after original director Tim Miller left
the project over creative differences
with Ryan Reynolds he was replaced by
David Leitch best
known for co-directing John wick
Deadpool 2 is set to smash through the
fourth wall on June 1st and remember
this is your world you get to make and
break the rules here
Jurassic world fallen kingdom when
Jurassic world roared into theaters in
2016 it quickly became the fourth
highest-grossing film of all time raking
in approximately 1.6 billion dollars
with that kind of success we all knew it
was only a matter of time before we went
back to that Dino infested Island and
now with Jurassic world fallen Kingdom
not only do we get to see the Raptors
run amok but we'll also watch an
abandoned theme park get blown to
smithereens this guaranteed blockbuster
promises to be an over-the-top spectacle
catch it June 22nd the purge the island
the purge franchise has been picking off
victims and making political points
since 2013 but have you ever wondered
how this night of bloodshed started
we'll finally get an answer to that
question would the purge the island the
fourth film in the series and the very
first prequel written by franchise
mastermind James demonaco the newest
film will take place before the Ethan
Hawke original it's set to hit theaters
on July 4th ant-man and the wasp
audiences are in for a marvelous time
when ant-man and the wasp arrives July 6
Paul Rudd and Evangeline Lilly will be
suiting up as The Namesake heroes and
they'll be joined by an impressive cast
two familiar faces and newcomers alike
but most interestingly Michelle Pfeiffer
is switching sides abandoning DC and
Catwoman to play Janet Van Dyne the
original loss in the first ant-man we
learned that Janet was lost inside the
quantum realm but now it looks like
ant-man and the wasp will somehow rescue
her from her decades-long adventure the
nun the conjuring series is quickly
making its case that a horror movie
franchises can be extended universes to
following in the success of Annabelle
the franchise's first spin-off producers
have tapped actress Bonnie Aaron's to
reprise her role as the demon nun from
the conjuring 2 and her own spin-off
titled simply the nun catcheth July 13th
Elita battle angel ever since the 90s
Jane
cameron has wanted to adapt gamoo a
popular japanese manga but now that he's
preoccupied with the avatar sequels
cameron has drafted Robert Rodriguez to
work on the project as a result we've
got Aleta
battle angel a sci-fi adventure starring
Rosa Salazar as a cyborg with amazing
martial arts prowess and controversial E
large eyes Cameron will finally see his
passion project in theaters on July 20th
Mission Impossible 6 Christopher
McQuarrie returns to helm a sixth
installment to the covert op action
adventure series and while details are
scant as to what the actual storyline
will be we know the film will delve
deeper into Ethan hunts backstory crews
trained for a year to prepare for some
truly insane action sequences as hunt
and we can't wait until July 27th to see
how the movie star puts his life on the
line this time the predator kicking off
a new round of interplanetary big-game
hunting the predator finds writer
director Shane Black who made a blanket
you'll miss at appearance in the 1987
original making a long overdue
return to the franchise the latest
addition to the series works as a kind
of sequel and follows a group of PTSD
stricken soldiers who band together to
kill the spine crackling alien hunters
expect our ragtag heroes to face off
against everyone's favorite skull
collector on August 3rd the equalizer -
on August 3rd Denzel Washington returns
for the equalizer - the actor is making
history here starring in his very first
sequel there aren't a lot of plot
details out there but come on we're
going to see Denzel Washington destroy a
bunch of bad guys in incredibly creative
ways what more do you need to know venom
Sony's plans for a spider-man Cinematic
Universe seemed to hit the skids when
the studio abandoned its Andrew Garfield
led amazing spider-man franchise in
favor of another reboot teaming up with
Marvel for joint custody of the
characters film rights and putting Tom
Holland in the web-slinger's duds
while the sinister six movie might still
be dead venom is officially back on the
schedule the alien symbiote antihero is
now slated to sling his way into
theaters on octo
fifth with Tom Hardy in the title role
Halloween
once again starring Jamie Lee Curtis the
latest entry in the Halloween franchise
will ignore every film except for the
original cult comedy mainstays David
Gordon Green and Danny McBride are
behind the sequel which is supposedly
going to be the last Halloween movie
ever but just like Michael Myers we
suspect the series will eventually come
back to life
catch the horror on October 19 fantastic
beasts the crimes of Grindelwald JK
Rowling's Harry Potter spin-off series
fantastic beasts and where to find them
is on deck for its second installment on
November 16th following Newt Scamander
and his pals on another adventure in the
world of Witchcraft and Wizardry the
sequel will feature a young Albus
Dumbledore played by Jude Law who
instructs our hero to chase down and
apprehend Gellert Grindelwald a
villainous wizard guilty of magical
crimes played by Johnny Depp the film
promises to begin the battle for the
ages between the esteemed professor and
his former bestie gone rogue spider-man
into the spider-verse
ever since Miles Morales first appeared
back in 2011 Marvel fans have
desperately wanted to see him get his
own spider-man movie on December 14th
Sony plans on releasing spider-man into
the spider-verse
an animated adventure following the
young webslinger as he fights crime Phil
Lord and Chris Miller of the lego movie
are credited as executive producers and
Lord penned the screenplay so expect to
see his unique brand of humor swinging
across the screen wait so how many OSA
Aquaman the introduction of Arthur
Aquaman curry in Batman vs Superman dawn
of Justice was but a taste of what was
to come from Jason Momoa as the Trident
wielding hero in Justice League with 20
18s Aquaman
Hill embraces destiny as the heir to the
kingdom of Atlantis director James Wan
Helms the watery actioner that will
follow Curry's life from boyhood to king
hood and Dolph Lundgren will show up as
a powerful Atlantean King that means on
December 21st were getting a film with
both Ivan Drago and Khal Drogo which
might be way too much muscle for one
movie to handle thanks for watching
click the looper icon to subscribe to
our YouTube channel let's check out all
this cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]